all right so now that the hierarchy of
power in the DC Universe has changed
forever seriously if I had a dollar for
every time I heard that Black Adam is
almost a reset button in a sense for the
dceu and that of which that has been
established over the past eightish years
or so but we're not dwelling on the past
let's look forward to the bright future
of the various dceu films that are set
to release the ones in development
rumored projects and the unfortunate
ones that are in some sort of purgatory
production hell one day my friends one
day we'll get that weasel Trilogy no
one's asking for now if you enjoyed this
video then battering that like button as
it helps the channel and prevents Paul
from firing me and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns Recaps and
other videos like this every day with
that out of the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's dive into the
video now as the team was editing this
video big news dropped cause in a shake
up at DC films as it was just announced
that James Gunn and Peter Safran have
taken on the roles of co-ceos of the DC
Universe which I'm guessing is now
solely the DCU suck it Kevin Studios but
truly the hierarchy of power has changed
with these two at the helm and in turn
could mean some of the shelved or
doubtful projects could be back on the
menu with guns seen Success With both
The Suicide Squad and Peacemaker series
creative juices will fly and who knows
maybe this is all an elaborate plan to
finally cross over the Batman and
Scooby-Doo in live action anyway the
next DC film ready for release happens
to be Shazam theory of the Gods hitting
Cinemas on March 17 2023 following the
release of Black Adam seems to be a
cheeky way of bringing the shazamly back
into things however the sequel doesn't
look like these two Gods will be facing
off just yet instead theory of the Gods
is bringing back the whole group we grew
to love in the first film along with
their superhero counterparts but instead
it's the villains of the daughters of
Atlas that they're going to be going up
against hespera Calypso and Athena
played by Helen Mirren Lucy Liu and
Rachel zegler respectively as they are
upset by how Billy and the others have
used the powers that they were given
they're gonna face off with the group
trying to retrieve them in what appears
to be a massive Transformers dragon
fight do you remember that dragon from
Transformers the last night what what
the hell was that thing now it's no
doubt that there's going to be a
post-credit scene that will set up a
Shazam versus Black Adam storyline
because of their connection to the gods
so anyone hoping for that Mr mind and
Mark Strong's Dr Savannah might pop back
up again
maybe in a Shazam three
next time
zooming into theaters on June 23 2023 is
the fastest DC hero the trash I mean the
flash featuring bad boy of the superhero
World Ezra Miller The Flash movie has
had hiccup after hiccup with directors
being switched out scripts being
reworked the title being switched from
the flash to Flashpoint and then back
again because of reasons along with an
apology to her by DC regarding their
lead but Andy mushietti is firmly set
directing this story which has been said
to be tackling the flashpoint comic
storyline in this Barry Allen crashes
through different dimensions changing
his mother's fate which in turn has a
huge ripple effect resulting in the
heroes that we've seen in the Justice
League to take on entirely different
story arcs there have been set photos of
multiple flashes uh flat flashers flash
people being featured along with Michael
Keaton's return as Batman from his stint
as the character dating all all the way
back to 1989. it's also rumored we're
going to see Michael Shannon and Asha
treya return as their characters from
Man of Steel along with Sasha Kali being
introduced as Supergirl this movie has
the potential to shake things up and
kind of rewrite what we know the DC EU
is potentially even resulting in a
recast of Barry Allen switching out
characters we've grown to love and even
dropping in other DC properties that we
haven't seen become part of this
established dceu as of now we'll see if
this Multiverse of Madness lives up to
the flashpoint name Beetleborg fans
Rejoice I know it's been a tough 25
years because Blue Beetle is crawling
into theaters on August 18 2023. now I'm
not too aware of who Blue Beetle is but
his comic Origins date all the way back
to 1939 there's been roughly three
different characters donning the Blue
Beetle mantle Dan Garrett Ted Korg and
Jamie Reyes with this theatrical
adaptation following the most recent one
Jaime Reyes Cobra Kai Stars sholo Mary
dawinia oh my gosh I totally butchered
that has been cast in the role which
follows a Mexican-American teen living
in Texas with his family when a
mysterious Scarab essentially attaches
itself to Reyes and turns out to be an
alien battle suit of some sort this
obviously shakes up his life with these
Newfound powers and responsibility
behind the scenes photos have given us a
great look at the superhero outfit that
he'll be wearing which is like spot on
from the comic book panels I'm
definitely intrigued by this newer
character now while plot details have
been scarce it's most likely going to
serve as an origin story to the
character with Susan Sarandon being cast
as Victoria cord the wife of the second
Blue Beetle Ted Korg she's supposed to
wind up being a villain of some sort I'm
assuming wanting the Scarab for her own
nefarious purposes again this is all
speculation so let me know your thoughts
on Blue Beetle and whether or not you
grew up with The Beetleborgs Aquaman and
the lost kingdom is set to go face to
face with one of the 17 Avatar movies
surfing into theaters on Christmas 2023.
now much like every dceu film there's
been a delay after delay being
attributed to post-production
difficulties mainly they don't have a
clue what is happening with the film do
they include Amber Heard who is said to
have her role significantly lessened and
even though bat flick is out as the DC
Batman he was spotted in a behind the
scenes video confirming that he is part
of the film maybe just a post-credit
stinger I mean who knows but Aquaman in
the lost kingdom is said to be revolving
around Black Manta pursuing his revenge
on Aquaman after the events of the first
film teaming up with Randall Parks Dr
Shin from the post-credits scene of that
movie orm The Ocean man
[Music]
he's also buying line for the Ocean
Master role once again director James
Wan stated he wanted to incorporate some
real world themes into this sequel
focusing more on a darker almost horror
aspects being largely inspired by the
1960s cult horror film planet of the
vampires which follows a crew being
drawn to a distressed beacon on a
strange Planet only to realize that they
are being manipulated into showing up
there as the strange creatures planet is
dying they seek an escape to the humans
world and are going to populate that
which I could see being used here you
know mirroring ecological events
happening today it is a bit odd though
because on the other hand Jason Momoa
has been stated saying that they are
leaning more into the comedy with the
script so who knows it could be the Best
of Both Worlds question mark the most
interesting one in this DC lineup has
got to be Joker 2. hitting theaters
October 4th 2024. the success of the
first Joker was unbelievable and
essentially it's a standalone it's in
its own world without the Caped Crusader
and even DC I'm sure was shocked they
had no clue this was gonna happen anyway
director Todd Phillips along with
Joaquin Phoenix are back in this sequel
titling It joker fola douche Foley uh do
I'm sorry pardon my French uh he here's
a picture of the script my apologies but
the French expression translates to
Madness for two and is defined as being
a shared delusional disorder between two
people which leads into the casting of
Lady Gaga as Philip's take on Harley
Quinn and going one further the sequel
is described as being a musical
comparing it to 1977's New York New York
approach as the first film took many
similarities from the 1976 Taxi Driver
film yup any sort of superhero mold of
the last decade is completely thrown out
of the window for this one the plot is
supposed to pick up after the muddled
events or delusions of the first Joker
so expect a lot of it to take place in
both um Arkham state hospital and Arkham
Asylum the musical aspects could solely
be from the Viewpoint of Harley Quinn as
well but this is still unconfirmed this
isn't supposed to be connected to the
greater dceu or even the Robert
battenson Batman film but if Money Talks
which it does they could make this into
kind of a prequel years and I mean years
before the Batman you know set in the
same universe those are the DC films
that we have the most information on so
yay but now let's jump into some of the
films that have been said to be in some
sort of development whether it be a full
script or just the name with some dollar
signs written on a napkin during a
Warner Brothers happy hour a third
Wonder Woman is currently in development
said to be fast-tracked after the fans
went mild after the lukewarm reception
to Wonder Woman 1984. again not much is
is known aside from Patty Jenkins coming
back to direct and Gal Gadot starring
Jenkins has kind of been divided
time-wise between this and a Star Wars
squadrons film however that was delayed
indefinitely much like every other Star
Wars film so work on the script is back
on track maybe just maybe a late 2023 if
loads of coffee is involved after the
success of the Batman it's no surprise
director Matt Reeves and Lead Robert
battenson are coming back for the sequel
though not much is known regarding a
release date or even plot details we can
assume that it'll be kind of the next
steps in Batman and Bruce Wayne's
Evolution AKA him becoming the kind of
Playboy Persona and the Caped Crusader
as for villains the Batman set up Barry
Keegan's Joker in a deleted scene along
with hinting at both the court of owls
and the villain of hush so it'll be
interesting where Reeves takes things
and how this also will connect with the
upcoming Gotham PD and Penguin series
coming to HBO Max there's also been word
that a second Batman series of films
would be popping off in the extended
world of DC films it's pretty much all
uh she said he said kind of situation so
take this with a lot of salt not not
just a grain but with the events of the
flash shaking things up this could
result in Ben Affleck returning to the
bat suit or even an older Michael Keaton
Batman that introduces other members of
the bat family like Robin or bat girl I
mean well Batgirl we'll get to that
later however with Walter Hamada
recently stepping down as head of the DC
films this could be complete nonsense
honestly and scrapped at this point Man
of Steel fans you've been waiting a long
and I mean long time for that sequel
well get ready because a girl of Steel
movie is in the works I have no problem
with female Heroes I'm just saying make
your own but yeah presumably this is
going to be be following Sasha Cali's
Supergirl who will be featured also in
The Flash movie it is unclear whether or
not she will be the official Supergirl
of the dceu or maybe she'll be teaming
up with Henry cavill's Superman in the
film we really don't know either way the
writer of the Cloverfield Paradox is
said to be tackling the script since
we're talking about super people let's
talk about the Man of Steel sequel
literally nothing was known about this
the whole concept was wrapped up in
Kryptonite with Henry Cavill never
wearing the suit again well the
mid-credits scene of Black Adam
completely changed that bringing a
shining Beacon of Hope because Henry
cavill's Superman makes a cameo this is
huge because he hasn't worn the suit
since 2017's Justice League and wasn't
even featured in the end credits for
Shazam or even Peacemaker so with him
seemingly coming back to the dceu shakes
things up potentially fast tracking this
long overdue Man of Steel equal with him
facing off against probably Black Adam
because uh if you remember the hierarchy
of power in the DC Universe has changed
forever again nothing but hope now
yeah as I was writing this Henry Cavill
dropped a video of him in the suit
stating its official that he is back as
Superman teasing that the suit in his
cameo in Black Adam are just a taste
just a taste of what's to come so expect
big news on this sequel soon
foreign
Lantern Corps film has been hinted at
and in development all the way back from
2014 when Justice League and everything
was kind of on the horizon however
things have kind of cooled down ever
since the Green Lantern series on HBO
Max was announced we may still see this
film which is once said to be featuring
old and new Green Lanterns with Hal
Jordan and Jon Stewart and described as
being Lethal Weapon in space I mean sign
me up because giant green fists and
someone complaining that they are too
old for this has got my money much like
Green Lantern a cyborg Standalone movie
was supposed to be released in 2020 but
uh yeah we're we're two years past that
and that did not happen actor Ray Fisher
who portrayed the Mr Robot Man voiced
strong opinions about the current DC
films leadership and the alleged
mistreatment during Justice League
reshoots towards director John Sweden
cyborg was to appear in The Flash movie
as well but has since been entirely
written out of that fisher vowed not to
work with DC films until something has
changed and with Walter Hamada stepping
down there could be a chance of his
return but very unlikely a black hawk
movie has seen some interest by director
Steven Spielberg yes the Steven
Spielberg with it following World War II
era fighters who then turn into
mercenaries it sounds like it would have
kind of no connection to the current
dceu unless it somehow weaves in with
Wonder Woman's Origins but again that is
a huge if because Steven Spielberg
hasn't really come back around on this
one Jared Leto's Joker was a interesting
adaptation to say the least and we're
supposed to see his Joker return in an
Untitled Jared Leto Joker project at
some point maybe not really yeah this is
probably not gonna happen it was said to
be a standalone Joker movie which would
then lead into a Harley and Joker
couples movie however with Leto's
comments regarding DC and the massive
success of 2019's Joker it seems like
Leto may have to keep all of those dead
rats and used condoms for himself a
Nightwing film was hinted to be a part
of the dceu master plan all the way back
in 2014 with it later bringing on Chris
McKay to write the script as recently as
2021 McKay said it's not lost yet
hinting we could see Nightwing on the
big screen at some point and if the
Gotham Knights game is any indication of
Nightwing's physique he is the total
package
a script for the interstellar
mercenarian Bounty Hunter Lobo is in the
works with screenwriter Jason Fuchs
being said to have finished a new draft
earlier this year aside from the rumored
Michael Bay connection and potentially
him directing it it seems like Lobo may
have to sit around puffing that cigar
just waiting an electrifying new project
featuring static shock is also in the
works at DC based on the Milestone comic
and animated TV show that honestly I
used to watch all the time on Saturday
mornings the electromagnetic teen is
supposed to be hit the big screen at
some point Michael B Jordan and Reggie
huddle are executive producing this
adaptation which could dive into the
greater DC Universe but more likely
start as kind of a standalone movie I
just hope we see my man surfing on that
manhole cover we already talked about
Superman and the return of Man of Steel
in a sequel but there is also a movement
on another Superman Standalone film
coming from JJ Abrams production company
Bad Robot featuring a black lead as our
Superman it is unknown which Superman
will be featured or even a multiversal
version of Clark Kent a short list of
directors has been rumored but with the
other Superman series Michael B Jordan
is working on along with this update
aided Man of Steel sequel news this
project like a few others is probably
going to be retooled after this in our
man project is in the works first being
announced in 2021 this one honestly
might be my most intriguing of the list
revolving around a man who takes a pill
that allows him to increase his strength
and endurance for only one hour and can
only be taken once a day hmm sounds like
project power took some liberties with
this idea anyway Gavin James and Neil
weidener are said to be writing the
script however there has been no word
since 2021 and a Black Canary movie
starring Journey Smollett from birds of
prey is said to be on its way though no
release date as of now the most recent
development was from June of 2022 with
smedlet stating that she was excited to
explore the character in a deeper way
this could be a follow-up to 2020s at
Birds of Prey or a fresh start in the
ever-changing DC EU film Universe now
it's time to pour one out for these next
few projects they aren't dead entirely
but have put into some sort of creation
Purgatory a hell and shelved will we see
them do we want to see them
um maybe first up is the trench which
was supposed to be a offshoot kind of
one-off story connection to the first
Aquaman focusing on you guessed it the
trench these were the fish monster
people that devolved from atlanteans
shown attacking Aquaman and the boat in
the first film now James Wan said he
wanted this to be a horror film focusing
on the species and the different realm
in the oceans that we haven't seen yet
Noah Gardner and Aiden Fitzgerald even
completed the script it's ready to go
however Warner Brothers shelved it
saying maybe one day now James Wan later
came out in 2021 stating that the film
would actually be a Black Manta Solo
movie starring Yaya Abdul mentine II
rather than focusing entirely on the
trench just like the trench a new Gods
movie was supposed to be honed by
director Ava Duvernay which would focus
on Mr Miracle Darkseid apocalypse with
Duvernay saying that she even looked
into tweets and kind of fan reception
for some of the casting saying quote I'm
taking notes however the same time the
trench was shelved this project was put
right alongside it a Wonder Twins film
starring KJ APA and Isabelle May was
said to be in development following a
kind of origin story in a sense with the
two learning to adapt to Earth along
with their powers the film was supposed
to be an HBO Max exclusive but was
entirely scrapped due to budget cuts as
it was budgeted around 75 million and
said that the characters were far too
Niche to be worthwhile the investment no
one knows you so get out of here and
lastly Batgirl who was done dirty my
friend so the Batgirl movie was said to
have been 70 done with its
post-production and one of the first HBO
exclusive releases but then it was
shelved deemed never to see the light of
day used as a tax write-off Instead This
was to feature Leslie Grace as Barbara
Gordon featuring an outfit similar to
The New 52 comics with a triumphant
return to the movies Brendan Frasier
folks was supposed to be playing Firefly
even with a lot of positives being said
about the film Warner Brothers scrapped
it because it didn't fit with the
company's strategic approach to maximize
secure Financial return translation
meaning it sucked or it wasn't gonna
make any money or it sucked and wasn't
gonna make any money either way DC may
have some bad press here or there but
they are working on a whole Bevy of new
exciting interesting and weird projects
I'd love to hear what projects you are
most looking for to and will we ever see
the Batgirl movie that is just sitting
on a shelf collecting dust right now and
I'll let you know we are currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of top gun Maverick on the 15th
of November and all you have to do to
get a chance of winning this is like
this video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below on what DC project you are most
excited for we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of last months are on screen
right now so if that is you message us
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos
whether it be our Black Adam ending
explained or our house of dragon finale
breakdown with that out of the way
thanks for your constant support I've
been Jared and don't worry we will get a
weasel movie one day just you wait I'll
see you in the next one take care and
peace